wir haben ein gigantisches plastik
problem auf unserer erde und es ist zeit
dass wir etwas tun und zwar für alle und
es ist ehrlich gesagt super einfach
plastik ist mittlerweile überall in
unseren körpern am straßenrand in den
wäldern und in den tiefen des ozeans
doch es gibt neue ideen um die riesigen
plastik berger zukünftig zu vermeiden
biokunststoff der im westen fall einfach
verrottet wie laub und das beste daran
mittlerweile ist es möglich ein bio
kunststoff aus kompostierbaren abfällen
herzustellen und wie wir alle aktiv
werden können dass am ende des videos
kriegs und science fiction
hier gibt's täglich spannende
wissenschafts videos abonniert den kanal
nur dann verpasst er nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen
es gibt wohl kaum etwas was so praktisch
ist die plastik das ist billig es hält
ewig und man kann es eigentlich in jedem
bereich einsetzen und genau deswegen
gehen wir wohl so verschwenderisch damit
um 250 millionen tonnen plastik pro jahr
produzieren wir weltweit allein in
deutschland entstehen 14 millionen
tonnen plastikverpackung pro jahr viel
davon schwimmt im meer herum ekelhaft
tödlich für tiere und dann als mikro
plastik mit zahlreichen schadstoffen am
ende wieder bei uns in der nahrung und
in der luft landet es auch und dann im
essen es ist wirklich schlimm
das haben sich auch die beiden brüder
denn jeff anderson beim surfen gedacht
und ihre firma namens fools eickel
bioplastics gegründet damit wollen die
beiden abwasser ingenieure dem
gigantischen plastik problem unserer
erde den kampf ansagen und gleichzeitig
vielleicht auch unser leben
revolutionieren
was sie dafür brauchen ist in
allererster linie organischer abfall
also beispielsweise essensreste müll aus
dem landwirtschaftlichen bereich oder
auch kartons die dann kompostiert werden
und zwar in einer eigens von ihnen
entwickelten kompostieranlage darin
laufen chemische prozesse ab und am ende
gibt es dann an abwasser dass sehr viele
fettsäuren enthält durch den einsatz von
bakterien werden dann genau diese
fettsäuren in poley druck süße teuren
sogenanntes micro verwandelt das ist
eine zähe und milchige masse die man
dann zur verpackung pressen kann das
tolle an diesem konzept anders als
andere hersteller werden hierbei keine
extra chemikalien oder
extra gezüchtete pflanzen benötigt und
wenn die produzierten produkte nicht
mehr gebraucht werden nimmt ihre firma
sie zurück um wiederum neues bio plastik
daraus herzustellen
doch selbst wenn es in der landschaft
oder im wasser landet ist es dort noch
lange nicht so gefährlich und schädlich
wie das konventionell hergestellte
plastik denn nach angaben der anderson
brüder verrottet es einfach auf
natürliche art und weise vergleichbar
mit laub die beiden anderson brüder
haben für diese innovative idee schon
viele preise abgeräumt und sie sind
nicht die einzigen die das plastik
problem der welt auf solch eine art und
weise angehen wollen der markt ums
bioplastik ist hart umkämpft und die
wachstumsraten weltweit sind gut
biokunststoffe sind schon aus vielen
verschiedenen materialien wie stärke
oder zucker beispielsweise produziert
worden
doch mit ernüchternden ergebnissen sagt
beispielsweise das umweltbundesamt denn
die prozesse brauchen viel energie
wasser und dort viel zu viel chemie vor
allem das fazit bioplastik ist nicht
gleich bio plastik der begriff
biologisch bedeutet in diesem
zusammenhang nicht automatisch dass das
hergestellte material auch biologisch
abbaubar ist oder auch ansonsten
umweltfreundlich anders bei dem bio
plastik der anderson brüder ihr
verfahren sei co2 neutral brauche wenig
energie und wasser kohlendioxid wird bei
ihrem kompost ihr system zunächst sogar
gebunden wenn die produkte dann später
kompostiert werden würde ist allerdings
wieder freigesetzt trotzdem der prozess
setzt kein zusätzliches co2 frei
doch was genau ist das problem warum
sind dann nicht schon längst alle
plastik gegenstände dieser welt
abgeschafft worden
die anders im ruder sagen dazu
realistischerweise dass man bei dingen
die sehr lange zeit überdauern sollten
nicht mit kompost arbeiten sollte ein
handy oder tablet aus biokunststoff wird
es also erstmal nicht geben dafür aber
vielleicht andere unzählige dinge die
eben nur einmal verwendet werden tüten
einweggeschirr oder verpackungen damit
sich das aber wirklich komplett
durchsetzen kann müssen solche konzepte
bioplastik herzustellen deutlich
günstiger werden
denn nur dann kann mit der
konventionellen plastikindustrie mit
gehalten werden
doch die chancen stehen gut denn der
einzige rohstoff der gebraucht wird ist
eben
abfall im überfluss vorhanden und zudem
kostenlos trotzdem
bisher liegt der umsatz von bio plastik
in deutschland wie in den meisten
anderen ländern dieser welt bei gerade
einmal knapp zwei prozent doch die
zahlen steigen das labor der anderson
brüder wird auch gerade erst noch fertig
gebaut bisher wird nur ein kilo von
diesem micro fett pro tag produziert
aber nicht nur in den usa sondern auch
in deutschland wird an solchen konzepten
gelüftet beispielsweise hat sich auch
die firma bio lotions aus hamburg auf
die produktion von bio plastik
spezialisiert doch das verfahren dazu
ist anders die produzierten verpackungen
bestehen aus faser haltigen pflanzen
abfall die verpackung von gemüse und
obst beispielsweise also bestehen
letztendlich aus bananen stemmen tomaten
stängeln oder zuckerrohr blättern werden
sie entsorgt verrotten sie sowie laub
dieser sogenannte phase gust so heißt
das verfahren funktioniert auch hier
ohne zusätzliche chemie konkret werden
die pflanzenreste hierbei zu nano und
mikrofasern zerkleinert wird wasser
hinzugefügt entsteht ein faser breit der
dann in verschiedene formen gepresst
werden kann
die pilot fabrik dazu steht in indien
der dort ist das plastik problem noch
größer als in deutschland pro monat
entsteht derzeit in der vw knapp eine
tonne bioplastik bevor das ganze konzept
marktreif ist kann schon jetzt jeder von
uns etwas gegen die gigantische mengen
plastikmüll tun alles was öfter benutzt
werden kann ist umweltfreundlich also
mehrwegflaschen im stoffbeutel also
mehrweg taschen oder im rucksack
steinweg tüten und wir können auch
einfach produkte kaufen die im papier
verpackt werden oder produkte die lose
verkauft werden in dosen apfel und und
ich werde jetzt ganz konkret damals
anfangen und ihr könnt mitmachen auf
instagram habe ich den account get rid
of plastics werde plastik los auf
deutsch und da sammle ich alles was es
ohne plastikverpackungen gibt
waschpulver habe ich zum beispiel
gefunden oder es gibt seife als
haarshampoo im papier verpackt hier
draufklicken und schickt mir dort eure
ideen mit fotos ich veröffentliche sie
dann und freue mich auf eure vorschläge
bis dann bleibt dran